Dr. Anthony Foushee, the top infectious disease
doctor in the country who has been trying
to run a coherent coronavirus response and
has been fighting against the White House
in order to do it, is now begging and pleading
with Americans to just listen to science,
understand and accept what's going on.
And it's like reasoning with little kids,
unfortunately, and much of this country.
Here he is on MSNBC again, having to explain
that we have a process for studying whether
a drug works and that hydroxy chloroquine
doesn't work.
Follow the science.
If a study that's a good study comes out and
shows efficacy and safety for hydroxy chloroquine
or any other drug that we do.
If you do it in the right way, you accept
the scientific data.
But right now, today, the cumulative scientific
data that has been put together and done over
a number of different studies has shown no
efficacy.
So when there's a video out there for a bunch
of people spouting something that isn't true,
the only recourse you have is to be very,
very clear in presenting the scientific data
that essentially contradicts that.
We have such an education crisis in this country.
We have such a media literacy problem in this
country that the top infectious disease doctor
is having to spend a non negligible amount
of time just explaining to people we know
how to study whether a drug works.
And this one doesn't work.
You shouldn't be taking it.
And meanwhile, Trump is insisting it's good.
Congressman covered Louie Gohmert says he's
taking it now that he has Corona virus.
And this is how Dr. Foushee is having to spend
his time.
Trump is still doing this in the last 48 hours.
Trump said the following activism explains
the recommendations of many of the people's
people, including doctors.
Many doctors think it is extremely successful.
The hydroxy chloroquine, coupled with the
zinc and perhaps the Z3 Myson.
But many doctors think it's extremely good
and some people don't.
Some people, I think it's become very political.
I happen to believe in it.
I would take it as you know, I took it for
a 14 day period.
And I'm here.
Right?
I'm here.
They seem to now see everything as a matter
of opinion.
It's all political.
Your opinion is hydroxy chloroquine works.
My opinion is that it doesn't.
These are just differing opinions.
The obvious hypocrisy here is that it's the
right that has come out waging this battle
against what they call postmodernism from
the left.
They claim, you know, the left thinks words
don't mean anything anymore.
Everything is just opinion.
There's no more real truth.
And yet they come out and then say, well,
our opinion is hydroxy chloroquine works when
it comes to what are the words man and woman
mean.
The right says the left is playing too fast
and loose with definitions and what things
mean.
And yet here they are saying it's a matter
of opinion if hydroxy chloroquine works.
Some people believe it doesn't.
As if science and medical studies don't have
anything to tell us about it.
If their opinion is that a mask could cause
harm or as Congressman Covered said a couple
days ago, give you Corona virus, then we have
to say, well, their opinion is theirs and
then we might have scientific consensus.
But in the end, it's all just opinions.
This is dangerous.
This is dangerous far beyond the corona virus
situation that we're dealing with right now.
And this is also another problem I've spoken
of in the past.
The idolizing of people over process, the
idolizing of a cult of personality when it
reigns supreme over understanding how we come
to know things.
And that's an issue we've been talking about
for years in the United States.
We had these are estimates maybe 60 percent
of the population will listen to science because
they understand how it works.
The other 40 percent is a combination of people
who sort of listen to science, even though
they don't really know how it works.
But it's sort of just like an argument from
authority for them and then an amalgam of
people who will follow their religion or what.
They believe their religion says or their
cult leader.
In this case, the cult leader can be a political
figure.
And this is unique to the right.
Imagine for a moment Joe Biden, where President
Corona virus hits.
And Joe Biden comes out and says, you know,
doctors say hydroxy chloroquine doesn't work,
but I think it does.
You should take it.
You're not going to see a lot of leftists
go and say Joe Biden said Hydroxy works.
I'm going to take it.
Even though doctors say no, this is a phenomena
of the American right.
It does not exist in the left to any kind
of significant degree.
And this is a cult like aspect of the right
in the United States.
And it's not just the type of thing we talk
about in academic settings.
This is causing very real and concrete problems.
And if you think it's bad now with this hydroxy
chloroquine stuff in the mask fiasco, just
wait until a vaccine comes out, which maybe
is 60, 70 percent effective.
But 40 percent of the country may refuse the
corona virus vaccine, as some studies expect
will happen.
40 45 percent of the country may opt not to
get a corona virus vaccine once it is available.
Horrifying.
Absolutely horrifying.
Make sure you're following me on Twitter at
David Pakman.
And remember, you can get the daily audio
podcast every day.
You don't have to watch the short YouTube
clips if you prefer a long form audio format.
When you're working out, when you're doing
whatever it is that you're doing, gardening,
your Zook's and CUCs, maybe like me.
Grab the audio podcast on iTunes, Stitcher,
Spotify, Pandora, whatever your favorite podcasting
app is.